à montigny l'heure est à la
reconstruction arrivé l'été dernier
l'entraîneur jean dany grosser récupéré
un groupe très jeune le maintien assuré
à cinq journées de la fin du championnat
de division 2 lésiné monteyne peuvent
désormais viser plus le challenge défi
ces filières laquelle premier en sachant
qu'un un moment et leader incontesté qui
va monter va monter en d1 donc c'est de
finir et on a des matches chater des
matchs intéressants et on peut on peut
se rendre la fin de saison agréable à
jouer et à se faire plusieurs points
logo pour ce groupe qui est jeune
le staff fini mon teint se projette à
moyen terme et prépare déjà la saison
prochaine recherche de sponsors et de
recrues l'objectif est affiché la montée
en première division mais en attendant
les coéquipières de margot robbie n'en
recevait ce week end l'avant dernier a
bien une rencontre dominée de bout en
bout john sampson ouvre le score en
fixant parfaitement la gardienne sur cet
intérieur du gauche
grâce à un doublé de margaux robinet
saint-quentinoise s'impose finalement 4
buts à 2 et deviennent la bête noire des
amiénoise avec trois victoires en autant
de matches avec ce succès désigneront
thème pointe toujours à la 7e place mais
à seulement trois points du podium